[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à sept autres
éditions dc espace autochtone en direct
je m'appelle anne-marie vont alors on
vous l'avait promis on nous allions
revenir une fois les débats terminé il y
en a eu quatre ne nous sommes intéressés
à deux débats les deux débats qui ont
été présentés à siby 6 et radio canada
il y en avait 1 lundi en anglais hier en
français donc on va revenir sur ces deux
débats avec nos trois invités
bonjour à tous alors c'est nos analystes
régulier pour cette campagne électorale
isabelle picard dont jour isabelle cindy
world bonjour cindy et puis avec simon
van loan
bonjour à tous les trois vous avez fait
vos devoirs en anglais en français oui
c'est très bien donc on va revenir sur
les deux débats mais première question
je sais pas qui aura envie de se lancer
le premier êtes vous satisfait de ce que
vous avez entendu pendant la campagne en
général moi je trouve que c'est pas une
campagne qui est très enlevante à mon
avis à mon humble avis une chance q les
quatre débat justement pour un peu
mousser le truc et pendant les débats il
ya eu des réponses à certaines questions
mais il ya eu et on y reviendra j'en
suis certaine des questions qui sont
restées des réponses qui sont restés
très vagues
et on se demande encore si les chefs on
dise vraiment ceux où ils veulent aller
où
finalement si on vraiment réfléchi à la
question d'un talent certain certains
domaines
oui cindy moi je dirais que j'ai eu des
surprises des belles surprises certaines
réactions
mais de façon générale mon constat c'est
que les partis politiques en ce moment
sont vraiment côté de nos priorités de
nos anges au niveau autochtone c'est ce
qui ressort avec 6 - feeling général que
j'ai comparé la dernière élection de
c'est que l'enjeu autochtones étaient
beaucoup plus présents dans la dernière
élection
on avait juste être d'eau qui allait
être le champion de la réconciliation
tout ça on l'a vu un peu avec les
promesses brisées peut-être qu'il y a
plus envie de autant s'engager à cet
égard mais c'est la même chose ici je
trouve dans les médias québécois
là le rapport vient qui a été déposée
disait que on l'aimé les médias
québécois gens invisibles et des
questions des premières nations qui je
pense que c'est un peu le coup aussi
il est intéressant de voir par exemple
on n'a plus répondu à des questions de
sommet les questions autochtones ou hier
quand on avait juste une question sur ce
sujet qui est comparativement toute une
section d'un débat malgré qu'ils aient
finalement on n'a plus vu sur qui sur
les débats sur les oléoducs
oui ça a quand même pris 55 minutes
avant que la première question sur les
autochtones dans le débat en français
surgissent d'ailleurs on pourrait en
profiter pour écouter ces échanges là
j'ai sorti deux extraits en fait à leur
premier extrait c'était la question qui
a été posée par patrie soit lors de la
confrontation à 3 donc c'est jack mixing
andrew scheer et yves françois blanchet
qui ont répondu la question était la
suivante on a parlé de génocide culturel
on a parlé des pensionnats des femmes
disparues des réserves sans logement ou
eau potable une question simple donc
allez vous faire concrètement pour
améliorer la condition de vie des
autochtones
on va écouter la réponse
ce que j'ai vu c'est monsieur trudeau a
donné deux beaux coups des belles
paroles en public mais c'est vraiment ce
que les décisions qui est le fait en
privé c'est le problème donc avec lucky
multi autochtone c'est clair si on veut
agir dès maintenant on peut agir
donc la question c'est ça si on respect
le fait que les enfants autochtones
on a droit d'avoir les mêmes
financements il ne faut pas les plots
suis dans le cour de justice comme ce
trou d'eau à fait ce que je fais je vais
respecter la communauté autochtone ça
c'est primordial
c'est la première étape c'est le respect
et la dignité
si on commence avec ça ça veut dire ont
bien fait un des finances la communauté
autochtone avec le financement égale
très bien c'est un débat monsieur cher
monsieur blanche à l'issue du sujet
merci beaucoup
une inspectent respecter les premiers
nation c'est de respecter quand les
communautés autochtones dit oui dit oui
au début des projets pour aider la
croissance économique
et quand on parle des communautés dans
les endroits éloignés au courage les
secteurs qui créent le plus d'emplois
pour les premiers nation c'est le
secteur minière des secteurs forestière
et le secteur énergétique est ce c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai dit que je
vais nommer une ministre avec leurs
responsabilités pour faire les
consultations dans une manière dynamique
pour assurer qu on respecte nos
obligations communes gourmand avec les
traités du blanche et les relations avec
les premiers peuples sont marquées par
un déficit de confiance parce que c'est
ma compréhension puis c'est la
compréhension qu'on doit en avoir parce
que ce sont de véritables nations avec
les mêmes droits privilèges obligations
et responsabilités que des véritables
nations mais il ya une déclaration de
l'onu d enquête d étudier des
commissions et je disais c'est eux qui
disent pour ce que je suis à l'aise le
dis pas ça doit venir deux jeux ça ne
vient pas une cas pas de suites
concrètes
donc on ne met pas en oeuvre des
démarches clair qu'on fait tout ce qui
était au ritz qui est beau puis pendant
ce temps là les solutions ne se trouve
pas le respect ne s'établit pas la
confiance ne se construit pas il va
falloir
modifier une relation profonde avec les
premiers peuples en douze ans que je vis
des populations
c'est pas un mot c'est une réalité
auxquels ils ont droit comme nous non je
suis tellement c'était le premier
extrait qui a été assez long mais bon ça
mais quand même la table ça explique
bien les choses vous avez tous les trois
réagi au même endroit quand andrew
scheer a parlé évidemment vous vous
attendiez à ce genre de réponse de sa
part
oui messieurs les autochtones sont bons
pour participer à l'économie canadienne
oui mais seulement quand il est question
d'exploitation des ressources naturelles
t1 quelque part c'est ça tourne toujours
autour de ça l'exploitation des
ressources minières forestières
énergétiques alors le oui on veut aller
consulter surtout s'ils disent oui c'est
un peu ce que j'entends et on dirait
qu'on existe pour le parti conservateur
que dans cette optique le et dont on
connaît la position de la plupart des
autochtones sur notamment les oléoducs
les pipelines bandiera moi c'est sûr que
ça fait réagir je suis pas surprise de
voir mes collègues et d'avoir réagi
également mais en fait ça a été aussi
son habileté à monsieur scheer de tout
casser les autres enjeux pour lesquels
on est heureux disait la question des
enjeux importants pour les premières
nations et j'ai aussi le mot
consultation qui me trotte dans la tête
on avait plus de consultations je pense
qu'on en ait fait le tour donc de re
médecins dans les priorités je vais
nommer ministre qui va faire des
consultations
ça fait pas avancer ça fait sens pour la
ce moment didier bonnet bien stone
indien qui dit oui à l'économie
[Musique]
selon monsieur c'est assez éloquent
comment il parle
je doute que c'est vraiment la façon
qu'ils pensent puis quelqu'un milliers
peut-être moins bon en français il y
avait moins de capacité de dire qu'est
ce qu'il voulait dire d'une façon plus
noir oui ils le disent directement
l'indien ses banques à ça dit oui au
parc alors il ya eu évidemment les deux
autres par contre avait l'air bon coup
beaucoup plus comment je dirais ça
beaucoup plus neutre parce qu'ils ne
répondent pas nécessairement la question
non plus on dit on veut on veut bien les
traiter mais personne n'a mène de plan
précis et de plan concret je trouve un
changement dans le débat anglais
comparativement française monsieur
blanchet dans le débat anglais on voyait
qu'ils mettaient beaucoup de l'avant la
relation des nations que le québec
revendique la position des nations est
là et comme compris que les autochtones
finalement c'est ce qu'ils revendiquent
aussi puis je trouve que son message
sans aller dans ce sens lancés à ses
trousses cette fois ci mais
effectivement il n'y avait pas rit de
concret et monsieur monsieur singh lui
parlait beaucoup de respect de dignité
ainsi revenue énormément dans dans ses
réponses et moi aussi je me suis
demandée bain dans le concret qu'est ce
que ça veut dire et un peu plus loin
quand même dans le débat il va partir il
faut parler d'eau potable il va parler
de deux d'un centre de désintoxication
pour de traitement en fait donc il faut
quand même donner des éléments concrets
c'est certain et monsieur blanchet j'ai
noté la même chose quand même et ça on
ne peut que le salut est là je veux dire
ce serait peu conséquences pour le bloc
québécois qui vise à faire reconnaître
l'état québécois donc comme une nation
égal et et de ne pas aller dans le même
sens pour les premières nations pour les
premiers poèmes donc ça c'est notable
mais soulagé aussi bien bien affirmé le
fils qui sont avait de l'argent pour un
patelin devrait avoir de l'argent pour
de l'eau absolument ça ça a été retenue
donc ce qui nous a étonnés en fait en
écoutant le débat parce qu'on l'a
publiée hier sur la page
des espaces autochtone le peu de
réactions des autochtones ya très peu de
gens qui sont venus réagir à ce qui a
été dit pendant la soirée est ce que
c'est étonnant est ce qu'on doit être
surpris je m'assure prise n'y avait pas
grain grand chose
très percutant personnellement non je
pas surprise on peut le voir à pt a
sorti un sondage ou faisait réagir
vivement fait réagir les jeunes mais on
m'a dit c'est pas les intentions que
c'est le consommateur qui ressortent
quand même majoritaire dans le sondage
chez les autochtones 26% des descendit
autochtone voulaient voter pour les
conservateurs
21 pour cent pour les libéraux 17% pour
le npd puis 16 pour cent pour le parti
vert explique sa commande à l'ouest des
nations autochtones qui sont pour les
projets énergétiques
cela dit les doigts d'avoir sa
circonscription mais qu'est-ce que je
pense aussi c'est que ça démontre un
gros un bris de confiance avec le club
al gallal d'ailleurs j'ai senti monsieur
trudeau je m'ennuie j'ai envoyé même un
tweet là dessus parce que je me disais
mon dieu il me semble que y'avait pas le
goût d'être là je le trouvais effacé je
le trouvais pas très combatif ce soit
quelques wii j'ai trouvé qu'à ses
réponses étaient c'est les mêmes
réponses qui avait donné mille fois donc
c'est peut-être pour cela on est
tellement habitué d'entendre tout temps
la même chose c'est peut-être pour ceux
qu'on réagit peu mais effectivement ce
sondage là moi aussi bon jeu je connais
pas l'échantillon mais ça me fait un
pull vie de ma chaise quand j'ai vu que
les conservateurs étaient en avance dans
les intentions de vote pour les
autochtones
en même temps la question de leur caisse
qui a été déterminé par d'un sondage no
6 23% des gens disaient que c'était
l'environnement le sujet le plus
important quand même 5 pour ça me paraît
donc il ya un peu une contradiction du
sida on voit que le sujet le plus
important c'est l'environnement mais les
conservateurs même si vous alliez dire
quelque chose non je vous ferai jouir
j'ai peur du monde et je te réveilles
on va écouter ce cas ce qu'a dit trudeau
dans la soirée parce qu'il ya eu un
autre extrait qui a été intéressant
c'était encore une confrontation puisque
de toute façon ça a duré huit minutes
dans le débat en français donc on
demandait pourquoi il était alors en
appel du jugement ordonnant au
gouvernement la 2de verser 40 mille
dollars à des enfants autochtones qui
ont été confiés à la protection de
l'enfance
et puis on lui disait vous ne deviez pas
être le champion de la réconciliation
on va écouter sa réponse on continue de
l'être
on est d'accord avec le tribunal qu'il
faut absolument compenser ses enfants et
on va le faire on va travailler avec eux
pour établir les bons niveaux mais on a
pu faire des investissements concrets au
cours des quatre dernières années on a
levé 87 avis d'ébullition d'eau à long
terme
après dix ans de monsieur harper whisky
a rien fait on a pu créer des nouvelles
écoles des nouveaux investissements en
partenariat justement avec les peuples
autochtones mieux comprendre il faut
continuer il y en a beaucoup plus à
faire
mais le grand chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations perry bellegarde a
reconnu qu' aucun gouvernement n'en a
fait plus que l'on reconnaît on n'a plus
affaire à mes goûts et messieurs mais
surtout dont ce n'est pas vrai parce que
le trim tribune des doigts humaine am
jugement et les avocats de notre
gouvernement votre gouvernement a
contesté la reso temps ce n'est pas vrai
que je vous avais dit que vous avez à
l'aise avec la décision les avocats de
deux mois faire la leçon fait un effort
de reverser le jugement en faveur des
enfants autochtones
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour 107 un
vrai scandale on est d'accord avec le
tribunal qu'il faut compenser ses
enfants on encore des problèmes ont
alors pourquoi ai je sais je sais de
quoi pourquoi avoir fait appel je te
dois parce que le l'échéancier de le
faire d'ici décembre ne fonctionne pas
avec les élections qu'on est entré dans
un an quand des pourvois en confiance et
ses enfants mais ça prend un peu de
temps pour l'avoir de la bonne façon
j'écris mon corps on entend des
problèmes aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
réserve tous les réserves n'ont pas
d'eau potable c'est pas une question
d'argent pour livrer ses services live
21 milliards de dollars que le grand
le dépensent dans les relations avec les
premières nations il faut changer le
système le syndic ou ne fonctionnent pas
et ça fait des années comme vous le
dites qu'on essaie de bâtir met en
relation avec les premières nations ce
qu'il faut faire c'est bien clair il
faut abolir la loi sur les indiens
il faut s'assurer qu'ils aient plus
d'autonomie sur les réserves
il faut s'assurer de développer un droit
de propriété sur les réserves
il faut qu'il y avait la richesse qui se
créent sur les réserves et oui il faut
aussi développer des pipelines pour
s'assurer en collaboration avec les
premières nations qui la richesse puisse
arriver sur les réserves c'est pas une
question est encore plus d'argent de ce
match c'est une question de changer
notre relation se traduira je suis tout
à fait d'accord qu'il faut passer au
delà de la loi sur les indiens
mais c'est à eux de décider le rythme
avec lequel ça se fait il ya plusieurs
communautés qu'ils ont déjà fait au
travail avec toutes les communautés pour
qu'ils puissent le faire mais à leur
rythme et dans le respect de leurs
priorités
très bien alors voilà ce donc là c'est
la réponse de la réponse de justin
trudeau
là encore je vous voyais réagir les
sourcil qui se fait à plusieurs
occasions qu est-ce qui vous a piqué
danser dans les réflexions la deux de
nos de nos candidats mais je trouve que
quand on entend monsieur trudeau tout à
l'heure je parlais de réponse peau
claire le ben moi je trouve que ce soit
c'est une réponse qui est peu clair il
faut faire les choses de la bonne façon
mais c'est quoi la bonne ouïe fond c'est
ça qu'on veut savoir oui j'ai
l'impression que ce qui veut dire ceux
qui voudraient travailler en amont pour
que des situations comme celle des
enfants autochtones enlevées dans leur
famille n'arrive plus ok d'accord mais
dealer de cette façon là et qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent faire aussi au niveau il
dit on va pas contester la décision du
tribunal mais peut-être le niveau
finalement de finance de financement
mais de comment de compensation
donner à chacun des enfants si on sait
pas c'est vraiment pas clair et le moi
ça me dérange la dignité des enfants
c'est qu'on décide d'aller en appel des
jugements l'heure c'est assez risible
pour des questions de délais quand on
aurait pu demander au tribunal plus de
délai un arrangement ou des choses comme
ça il y avait des moyens de se faire de
jugement je trouve que c'est parler des
deux côtés de la bouche on est d'accord
avec le jugement mais on porte en appel
et qu'est ce qu'on doit penser alors
s'il était réélu par exemple ça voudra
dire quoi ben moi je les trouve pas lu
mes deux collègues parce que je suis un
gros mensonge c'est vraiment affronté de
de nous dire on accepte la décision mais
d'un autre côté on semble contredire
qu'on va prendre les moyens légaux
encore une fois prêt à les contredire
une décision qui était rendu justement
pour la dignité noz enfin pour ceux
comme non ça c'est une autre rupture
puis pour faire du pouce un petit peu ce
qu'on disait tantôt il était peut-être
effacé c'est ce que je l'ajouté c'est
que trouve son discours dans sa campagne
ce trudeau se sert beaucoup de disques
au prix marché un petit peu il sait plus
sur beaucoup sur ce que l'apn a dit je
sais pas comme une fois j'avais entendu
cette semaine mais c'est parce que le
père hubert a dit qu'on veut entendre
c'est ce que lui a à dire lui ce qu'il
faut faire et les gestes qu'ils posent
parallèlement baissé de faire une
protestation par exemple sur cette
décision alors pour moi ça parle
beaucoup quand on a ouï dire maquis qui
est efficace ou six dans le dossier de
l'eau en anglais on était quelque chose
comme 76
communauté qui avait réglé le problème
d'orientation été rendu à 87 quelque
chose à ajouter
c'est vrai que 87 avis sauf qu'il ya
encore là je me questionne sur la
possibilité de mensonges et plus vous
allez me trouver négative mais c'est
parce que on une collègue laurence qui
est fait un reportage et qui tiennent
kitigan zibi les leçons dans les
ébullitions et enlevait finalement oui
on le sait dans le concret qu il faut
encore une ébullition dos des gens se
font livrer l'eau à leur porte donc ça
fonctionne pas si son regard des 87 on
va les voir mener dans leur propre
communiqué marc louis et 87 levé par
contre un an j'étais 39
mais ça on l'entend pas dans le disco
essais marqués sur le site du ministère
dans caire moi j'ai des zones ne sont
pas très claires manger des salades
questions par rapport à cette complet à
ses angles oui oui on entendait maxime
bernier réagir à ce que justin trudeau
disais qu'est ce que vous pensez de dé
la plate forme de maxime bernier
vis-à-vis les autochtones et ce qu'il
répond à justin trudeau comme ça peut
laisser des tapas de double avec le
livre blanc de mettre fin au système de
réserve et mettre fin au système des
décennies ça a été répondu par le livre
rouge qu'est ce que les premières masson
on veut est-ce qu'on va falloir se
sortir du système de loi sur les indiens
si sûr mais va falloir qu'on le
définisse nouma je n'ai pas envie que ça
soit maxime dernier à tout le moins
limitée nissan et steve civitas qui
propose je trouvais que ça sortait
d'heure je sais pas où c'est sûr maxime
bernier qui propose on abolit la loi sur
les indiens sa sardou s'est appuyé sur
quoi et y es tu venu consulter nos chefs
je pense que fait l'étude préalable
absolu il parlait beaucoup c'est
d'accorder un des droits de propriété
mais pour accorder des droits de
propriété pour des autochtones c'est
justement il faut il faut un
à lire la loi sur les indiens ou en tout
cas il faut il vous l'a complètement la
transformer certains droits qui peuvent
partir avec ça donc je pense turcs
avaient fait les études préalables à ce
qu'il disait
il disait tout le temps le développement
c'est ce que j'entendais le
développement des premiers peuples passe
par les pipelines je l'entendis le
presque 10 mot-à-mot le moment donné
dans le débat ça encore mis les doigts
du don débat en anglais comme en
français
donc nous intégrer de la système
économique l'a toujours monsieur chier
c'est à peu près le même discours ou
siemens peu plus nuancé si vous
souhaitez gré quand quelque chose sinon
ça va être chaud de konami
oui ce qui n'est pas rassurant à
entendre mais quand il parle par exemple
d'abolir la loi sur les indiens bon vous
dites il n'a pas été consultée est ce
que c'est une réponse qui peut être
facile qu'on peut donner en dira ça va
plaire à tout le monde mais je pense que
monsieur bernier au lycée le ya peu de
chances d'être élu
donc je dirais comme premier ministre
quelque part il peut bien dire ce qu'il
veut les conséquences sont plus ou moins
importantes en ce moment c'est ce que je
suis on n'a pas parlé d'elizabeth may
elle même
en fait la plupart des candidats sont
venus renchérir sur le bilan de justin
trudeau
mais très peu ont exposé leurs actions
concrètes ce qu'il compte faire
pas plus d'ailleurs madame mais que les
autres candidats mais est-ce que sa
réflexion vis-à-vis les enjeux
autochtones sont venus vous interpellez
où vous cherchez des juges qui avaient
sauté sur la question de l'hérault du
que le changement climatique c'est des
questions importantes pour les
autochtones certes mais il y avait déjà
tout un segment à ce sujet puis c'est à
tout le temps à taper sur ce clou l'eau
tandis que les verts ont une plateforme
intéressante pour les autochtones ça a
été un bon moment de la partager oui je
m'emmêle exactement dire ça et je me
demandais si c'était pas au niveau du
langage
peut-être qu'elle avait un petit
spectacle la france et je souhaitais
l'entente davantage sur les autres
enjeux parce que l'environnement
elle nous est derrière on a les mêmes
sans joker les mêmes priorités mais par
rapport à sa plateforme 5p silencieux
donc je trouve ça dommage et l'eau quand
même parler du respect de la déclaration
des droits des autochtones je me
souviens plus si le débat en anglais ou
en français
elle a parlé aussi un anglais dont et du
du respect des appels à l'action de la
commission vérité-réconciliation donc
c'est quand même c'était intéressant
mais effectivement elle aurait pu aller
plus loin je trouve dans un nouveau de
sa plateforme elle a vraiment un segment
très intéressant en fait pour ce qui est
de la maison de la déclaration des
nations unies ils étaient tous d'accord
pour le faire bon sauf évidemment si je
sais cher monsieur bernier 60 oui
exactement ça mais pour avoir des
conséquences la souveraineté
territoriale du canada et livrer ben oui
mais de combien de fois à définir le
consentement préalable qu'est ce que ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire là il était
comme pour l'une conditions et si cette
définition de lui si belle peut-être que
si ce n'est plus ce que je sens oui oui
oui on parlait là lors de notre première
rencontre notre premier échange on se
disait ok on va laisser de côté la
réconciliation pour parler de
décolonisation est-ce qu'on est près
d'arriver à cette discussion là alexis
avec sk d'un vieil âge parce que
les plateformes des verts et des du npd
vont dans ce sens là
moi j'espère que c'est moi qui doit y
avoir un gouvernement minoritaire
libéral où ils seraient obligés de faire
des alliances avec les pays des piles et
je pense que si on parle de realpolitik
c'est qu'est ce qui pourrait faire en
sorte que les intérêts des premières
nations soient de mieux défendus avec le
bloc ou six qui pourrait peut-être avoir
dans la balance pouvoir puis on sait
qu'ils sont en faveur d'un déclaration
universelle des droits des peuples
autochtones d'une relation de nation à
nation donc je pense que dans un
gouvernement minoritaire pour avoir des
choses que intéressante pourrait
accepter pour les premières nations
avez vous le même point de vue mais en
fait moi tout ce que j'ai à dire là
dessus c'est que dans 1 face à ret dû
ressortir d'un dd de tous les candidats
parce que c'est une priorité pour les
premières nations
on l'a vu dans une lettre ouverte cette
semaine du chef picard oui il ya
d'autres aspects là j'ai des constats
comme je le disais d'entrée de jeu que
nos enjeux ont comme était passé
qu'est-ce-qui sécurité publique les
rapports laine fada vient on n'est pas
revenu là dessus le double alors que ça
vient juste de sortir la une comme si on
vient leur apport est arrivé là en
pleine campagne électorale jean non au
chef qui réitère l'importance de tous
appuyé le jour même du débat c'est vrai
je trouve qu'elle quand même l'époque
qui ont été faits par rapport à ce que
j'ai vu dans le passé notamment du bloc
québécois t on en parle mais il
reconnaît vraiment les nations
autochtones ce qu'ils disaient
exactement ce qu'ils doivent participer
aux décisions qui les regarde c'est pas
à nous c'est comme gouvernement ou comme
parti politique donc déjà l'heure je
trouvais qu'il y avait une sensibilité
que j'avais prévu oui absolument donc ça
et monsieur cinq ou six j'ai senti au
niveau de la bd qui avait une
sensibilité
bon c'est peut-être pas tout l'air mais
justement on sentait que pour elle qui
voulait faire les choses avec les
premiers peuples les entendent puis
travailler ensemble il me semble que les
yeux une avancée mais ailleurs
effectivement dans des dents les deux
conservateurs les libéraux on n'en sort
pas on a tout le temps 7,7 viser un peu
paternaliste des choses
ce qui est extrêmement dérangeante on
avance post une roue qui tourne oui ce
soit monsieur blanchet qui le disent
bon bah c'est mais personne en danger
aussi mais en fait on aurait dû
l'entendre de la bouche
justement des partis les plus importants
les partis principaux et ça ne l'a pas
été le cas
qu'est-ce que ça annonce pour l'avenir
parce qu'on sait que c'est pas il
françois blanchet qui va être premier
ministre du canada dans deux semaines
s'annoncent incertains statu quo selon
moi ou un d'avancées très lentes regard
jo sont aussi conviés au dossier de
l'eau je regardais ce matin sur le site
du ministère il ya encore 500 1,36
chantier d'ici deux ans et se pose
déterminé j'en doute beaucoup oui oui
qu'est-ce que ça annonce
si les libéraux deviennent majoritaires
ça on peut regarder de les quatre
dernières années puis voir que oui
peut-être avoir des émanations mais ça
risque pas d'être à la vitesse on le
souhaite
oui puis pourtant il ya des besoins et
annoncer le ccri ces chiffres et puis on
n'entend rien dans les promesses
électorales
c'est très inquiétant je trouve que si
avait pas eu ces segments là dans les
débats c'est un peu ce que j'ai sur des
porcs on est ce qu'on aurait vraiment
entendu parler des autochtones si ça
n'avait pas été des journalistes qu'il
est ok il faut ou monsieur madame tout
le monde
il faut poser la question autochtone
c'est pour quelque chose qui revient
automatiquement le puis ça devrais je
dire on la question autochtone doit être
au coeur de tout ce qui se passe au
canada aussi une des des réalités qui a
des conséquences d'ailleurs dans la vie
des autochtones c'est le manque de
logements ce sont ces logements qui sont
surchargés la ya énormément de familles
qui vivent dans dans un logement
plusieurs personnes jamais ça n'a été
abordé pendant les deux débats jeu saw
québec qui manquent 9000 unités de
logement 7000 mais ont besoin de
réparations pour des conditions
insalubres
c'est énorme ce c'est juste le québec on
parle de logement qui est hyper
important parce que ça des conséquences
plein d'autant un jeu la santé
la santé au manque d'infrastructures nos
transports sont compliquées dans les
communautés qui sont éloignés on a des
services discriminatoire ce n'est d'être
relevé par des commissions d enquête la
sécurité publique c'est la même chose
sous financement comprenant par un sapré
pire c'est près de denges russie
conservateurs entre pouvoir avoir
l'attitude de monsieur il ya aussi parce
qu'on peut entrevoir aux à venir c'est
extrêmement préoccupant honnêtement le
vraiment et j'entends de plus en plus de
gens des premières nations qui disent tu
fais pas sûr d'aller voter mais le je
vais y aller j'ai trop pas encore le
vote le vote de contestation le même
contenu en 2015 doit même quand on est
en 2011 pour ceux qui sont allés voter
ça serait le fun de maman d'haneda les
volumes d'achats entendu contraire dans
mon entourage et des gens qui avaient
l'intention d'aller voter
le son du comme je vais aller voter
pourquoi il n'y a pas un gouvernement
qui qui possiblement prérentrée qui vont
tirer sans mépris renommée en jeu donc
mais là la philosophie derrière et la
main lundi soir on conteste d'une
manière ou d'une autre le type pour pour
changer les choses mais ça cette fois un
moment donné comme comme autochtone
aller voter pour un parti qui ne
comprend vraiment pas vraiment qu'ils
adressent vraiment nos enjeux de 2,1
alors si on regarde les six partis en
lice lequel vous comprend le mieux moi
sans gêne cnp des partis faire pour
l'instant
c'est sûr que comme on dit est-ce qu'ils
ont des chances de rentrer donc ce qui
est dit pour possiblement faire son
chemin vers quoi c'est pas nous c'est
sûr que le npd pile le parti vert ont
des plateforme intéressante
le bloc s'est commis ou situation
intéressant puis comment les choses en
ligne saas pourrait très bien qu'on soit
dans un gouvernement minoritaire
ça ça pourrait être une très bonne chose
je pense pour les premières nations mais
pour le climat ou si c'est gégé
j'ai aimé entendre madame midi est ce
que vous voulez après les élections
faire un cabinet d'urgence climatique
comme un cabinet d'urgence de guerre
parce que on est rendu là dans une
urgence climatique
il va falloir prendre des actions il va
falloir aller au delà de la partisanerie
donc j'espère que pour nos enfants pour
nos sociétés que l'on peut savoir
gouvernement minoritaire qui vont faire
en sorte que des verres de lait npd
puisse peut-être dans la balance pouvoir
peut justement être le chien de garde
des questions sociales puis des
questions des questions
environnementales parce que comme jack
meeting d'hier libéraux font souvent
soit il clignote à gauche pendant
l'élection qui tourne à droite du
pouvoir
je suis d'accord avec alexis je pense
qu'un gouvernement minoritaire mais en
fait avec ce que j'entends au niveau des
autochtones je pense que ça serait
probablement la meilleure solution
le npd les verts oui notre nous
rejoignent je pense comme comme on le
dit si j'ai beaucoup aimé ce que le bloc
audi aussi la reconnaissance de la
nation et je pense qu'il était temps
lors que ce soit au niveau du bloc au
même parti québécois qu'on fasse parce
que je dirais même année ça fait pas de
sens que ça réclame est une nation qui
pendant longtemps t on en comptait pas
sa nation et des autres c'est comme deux
poids deux mesures donc j'ai vraiment
aimé ça je pense que monsieur blanchet
est un allié des premières nations
honnêtement et et on pourra avoir un
écho là aussi le spécialement au québec
alors les autochtones
évidemment ce n'est pas un bloc
monolithique chacun aussi à sa façon de
voir les choses d'un bout à l'autre du
pays il ya aussi de grandes divisions au
sein des communautés autochtones et des
différents groupes et on le voit
évidemment avec le sondage dont vous
parliez un petit peu plus tôt aussi donc
les intentions de vote ne seront pas les
mêmes d'une partie est ce qu'il ya une
division entre eux ce que pensent les
autochtones du québec est ce que
pensaient les autochtones du reste du
pays
mais je pense que des enjeux qui sont
similaires et très préoccupant au niveau
du logement entre autres l'eau potable
tout ce qui touche à l'environnement
également là il ya aussi des dissensions
pour l'exploitation des ressources
mais il reste que les enjeux
prioritaires à la base la santé le
logement et la sécurité publique je
pense en tout cas je peux parler pour
tout le monde je pense que c'est
partager à travers le pays tous ces
enjeux là donc on est là comme si on
vient parler notamment ben c'est la taz
et banon se départager partout les
conditions sont les mêmes
c'est sûr qu'il ya des différences je
pense un endroit comme grassy narrows et
je veux dire c'est pas la même réalité
kawanda qui par exemple oui on s'entend
mais en tant qu'autochtones on a tout la
même discrimination le système il est le
même une région dont on entends tu
entendu parler en fait un groupe même ce
sont les inouïe il n'a jamais été
question pendant des débats
j'ai entendu madame mais parler
brièvement de l'artiste pour parler des
changements climatiques mais c'est la
seule mention que de lover les gens
tendent pourtant ce sont des enjeux
primordiaux
on parle de plus en plus de ces
ouvertures dans l'arctique pour
rejoindre les autres pays circumpolaires
commence à se faire un nom bien sûr
comment ça se fait qu'on n'ait pas plus
proactifs que les candidats ne s'y
intéressent pas davantage est-ce que
c'est pas une question de nombre
les minutes sont pas tant que seul le
poids est pas énorme pendant longtemps
c'était la même chose pour les premières
nations mais là on a tellement fait de
place dans les médias on a tellement
cogné aux portes que ion plus en plus
choix nous entendre mais les inuits ont
peut-être pas fait de la même manière
cet exercice là alors peut-être que ils
veulent mettre leur leur déclaration
leur énergie ailleurs jeu
je pense que ça pourrait éventuellement
y les élus aux deux qui sont pas prévues
par l'homme donc eu peu d'intérêt pour
les partis politiques alors que pour eux
on le voit pour les partis politiques
c'est l'enjeu primordial
et c'est là qu'ils veulent justement
aller chercher les autochtones pour pour
les maîtres de leur côté finalement
oui mais il reste quand même pour les
zones où il ya des questions à se poser
au point de vue changements climatiques
parce que c'est les premiers touchés
mon usine ou et me disent les lives de
jeu mais conséquente au chat aux
mathématiques il réalise sur le ternois
oui c'est pas parce qu'on a qui n'en
parlent pas que c'est pas important je
pense qu'il devrait faire partie
intégrante du débat autochtone
effectivement il ya des réalités qui
sont quand même différente notamment au
niveau environnemental
oui alors il reste quelques jours à la
campagne
qu'est ce que vous voulez entendre là
d'ici le 21 octobre de la part des
candidats
la part de justin tu donc qui décide
finalement de pas contesté de pas dans
l'appel du jugement du tribunal des
droits de la personne
parce qu'ils pourraient se commettre
d'ici 21 octobre il ya des questions de
délais je sais pas exactement c'était
quoi les délais ondelettes au bout des
lèvres mais oui je trouve que ça serait
la cohérence n'est pas le jugement puis
on voit pas le contester
ça serait la moindre des choses sinon
pour delà de la part des opérateurs ont
reconnu être la plate forme d'un
brushing la wii les conservateurs elle
sortait aujourd'hui à midi on l'a pas
sous les yeux bon parce qu'on est en
pleine émission
pensez vous qu'un chat va sortir du sac
qu'on va avoir des surprises inattendues
je me savais encore le développement des
autochtones oui mais liés au
développement des ressources naturelles
jans convaincant pour le monde qui
disent oui oui absolument ça il ya parlé
aussi dans un débat de
nommé ministre ou une responsabilité
ministérielle pour justement définir la
négociation tout ce qu il négocia sion
avec les autochtones donc ça savoyarde
j'en suis certaine définir le
consentement préalable
entourant la déclaration des droits des
autochtones ça ça va y ait mais au-delà
de ça je pense qu'il y aurait déjà sorti
ses lapin du chapeau fille j'espère
juste de voir autrement que françois n'a
mis autochtone canadien dans sa plate
forme parce que moi ça méritait beaucoup
plus d'argent voulant sûrement dit ces
espaces autochtone n'est pas canadien en
dépôt québécois donc si je trouve ça
très paternaliste comme comme façon de
faire ce sera mon souhait rejet
programme l'attend
et puis de la part de monsieur trudeau
mendousse la cassette le
je dirais on entend toujours la même
chose ça serait bien entendre autre
chose d'aller au delà de ça il ya quand
même fait de bonnes choses qu'ils
parlent de ce qu'ils aillent plus loin
mais on est tous temps dans la même
cassette montre que je n'écoute plus là
honnêtement j'ai trop entendu là c'est
moi et moi j'ai pas d'attendre ces deux
partis l'homme est peut-être l'un d'eux
[ __ ] le bloc est parti vers de peut-être
plus déployer leur programmation voir
les premières nations en dessous de 2
publiciser parce que nous on est allé
fouiller dans leurs promesses
électorales et tout ça mais je pense que
le grand public ne s'est peut-être pas à
quel point ils sont prêts à se commettre
tous engagés donc je vois ce serait bien
est ce que le grand public est intéressé
à le savoir
c'est une autre question est ce que le
public était intéressant qui se tient en
octobre
ça c'est une autre question si on parle
de nous quand on dépose des des rapports
mais comme le disait d'elle comme c'est
bien mon analyse est beaucoup dans les
médias qui on devine avec la lettre ou
shake your c'est un petit peu dans la
presse est sorti un petit peu ici à
esparros autochtone mais ça a été un
peuple lassé diffusion domaine mais
aussi je pense à mon anglais oui mais en
fait moi juste comme ça tu es souvent
les médias sociaux
j'interpelle les gens je leur demande ça
vous intéresse pas il ya tellement
d'enjeux
vous êtes curieux vous voulez pas nous
inviter on va aider des gens qui qui
seraient des bons porte parole ou des
chefs qui seraient prêts à les expliquer
nos enjeux qui sait comme silence radio
je comprends possible je comprends pas
avec tout les rapports qui sortent après
l'autre on en a des enjeux importants
s'écriant pire comme l'environnement
c'est urgent en ce moment mais le
logement celle là encore la sécurité
publique pour les français les encore la
santé
je comprends je comprends pas de la
maison je trouve que c'est dans certains
sujets certains domaines l'on peut être
intéressant ces e-bonds j'en reviens
encore ressources naturelles mais
l'économie là ça peut être intéressant
mais quand même mieux et dans le débat
anglophone et dans le débat francophone
un bloc qui concernait les questions
autochtones et sont nos pauvres seuil il
ya deux élections c'est quelque chose
qu'on voyait donc quand même une
amélioration et si ces questions se sont
posées dans les débats c'est parce que
les gens lui demandent donc je pense que
quand même une curiosité
maintenant faut voir dans quel domaine
il ya d'autres choses qui peuvent être
adressés que l'économie oui plusieurs
les enjeux sociaux et bien sûr puisque
quelque chose justement quand ça fait
pas la faire en vrai qu'on en entend pas
vraiment parler de séquences a peut être
aidé à qu'on va en entendre parler
alors si les principaux partis en parle
peut maintenant est-ce que c'est
inquiétant pour l'avenir pour les quatre
prochaines années si ça fait pas partie
de leur plateforme électorale comment
est ce que vous voyez l'avenir
concernant les enjeux autochtones est ce
qu'on va avoir tendance à se tourner
vers vous plus souvent ou moins souvent
c'est une bonne question je pense qu'on
va encore comme premières nations comme
minutes de voir cogner à la porte très
très fort ouvrir des portes comme on le
fait on est habitué à se battre on fait
ça depuis des générations
mais justement ça serait bien comme je
le dis dans l'émission la semaine
dernière que les portes soient plus
ouverts
à une véritable discussion de nation à
nation dans le respect dans la dignité
donc on remettre des bases nautiques on
reparte à zéro qu'on voit comment est ce
qu'on peut faire les choses moi je pense
que ça serait essentiel sinon ça va être
encore la roue qui tourne
puis on y reconnaît le port mais en fait
l'assemblée du premier chef le disait
très bien dans sa lette c'est que si le
gouvernement est pas prêt à s'engager
mais nous on n'hésitera pas à aller vers
les instances internationales
donc je pense que c'est un bon moyen on
y visible un peu plus sans doute dans la
semaine que dans notre propre pays
donc et servons nous en plus comme vous
savez le disais je pense que cette
bataille là à dure depuis des années
donc on loge pas ça toujours eu qu'en
parallèle de toute façon donc nous on
continue puis en espérant qu'à un moment
donné on va voir de plus en plus
d'alliés on en oubliait il ya eu des
avancées on doit le reconnaître le cpo
est pas noir partout mais c'est ça oui
c'est inquiétant
puis en même temps je pense que le
meilleur des scénarios c'est justement
ce si on a un gouvernement minoritaire
pour balancer fait réagir un peu comme
un surveillant fluide mais loris nery
fondée par défoncer pour des médias
d'autres des instances internationales
quand j'espère comme je le veux savoir à
travailler dans le domaine du droit ça
souvent été un levier pour faire avancer
nos causes donc et je parle va falloir
continuer encore l'abattage de l'été
quand le voir avec le dossier sur les
affaires les d'aussi territoriaux
souvent on aurait pas de cause en
justice les gouvernements à agir et pas
et vous êtes de plus en plus à prendre
la parole à être entendu et je pense que
ça c'est très important aussi
oui une chance puis c'est aussi parce
qu'on ne fait une place est ici et là
tranquillement weepu faut pas se le
cacher au monde
avant on avait beau cogner longtemps ça
répondait pas mais là il ya quand même
une certaine place qui est faite donc
tranquillement je pense que c'est ça
peut être est dans bien sûr merci
d'avoir suivi ces débats semences a
peut-être pas été vos soirées les plus
excitants
c'était important de le faire par contre
dans la fonction france et a quand même
eu moins qu'à cocher oui et puis on va
se retrouver en fait au lendemain de
l'élection lorsqu'on saura quel
gouvernement sera au pouvoir lorsqu'on
sera qui sera assis dans quelques
chaises et là on va pouvoir discuter
d'avenir on va essayer de prévoir les
choses ça vous va oui d'accord merci à
tous les trois isabelle picard merci
infiniment samedi world indique simon
van loan à l'onu bon vote n'est ce pas
21 octobre et à très bientôt
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
encore une fois on se retrouve donc la
date n'est pas encore précisée en fait
ça va dépendre quand le gouvernement va
le prochain gouvernement va s'installer
donc quand on pourra savoir qui et dans
quel poste nous allons nous aussi
revenir pour pour en discuter tous
ensemble à très bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]
je
de la réconciliation oui et on est et on
continue de l'être
on est d'accord avec le tribut